today's video was made possible by
masterworks masterworks is the only
platform making it possible to own parts
of a multi-million dollar work from
iconic artists like picasso basquiat and
many more skip masterworks waiting list
using our link below more on this later
in 1991 the world's second largest
military power and one of the world's
most powerful armies faced an uncertain
future thousands of men of military age
with elite training and advanced
knowledge in terrible soviet practices
has signed up by military companies and
survivors soldiers of fortune if you
have a problem if no one else can help
you and if you have enough money then
maybe you can hire them the russian team
[Music]
but visualpolitik fans don't think for a
second that we are exaggerating around
the globe there are currently dozens and
dozens of military force companies
operating in international conflicts
especially in africa they are the
so-called pmc private military companies
and no we are not referring to the gods
that you find in shopping malls or the
neighborhood watch service that you have
contracted we are talking about real
organizations of soldiers with advanced
military training and equipment who were
hired out for money want to know more
about the unknown world of private
armies well let's get started
[Music]
our private army is a phenomenon unique
to eastern european countries well no of
course not because even though the a
team was a fictional series the
underlying concept is very real much
more so than we might think both in the
east and in the west though of course
there are some differences
[Music]
in the west there is also a significant
industry of private military and
security companies however they are
somewhat different from those we can
find for example in russia thus while
russian companies of this type do
provide combat services on a regular
basis western companies which are mainly
american focused mainly on providing
military support protecting key
infrastructure including of course
military infrastructure or carrying out
advanced technical work however they are
usually but not always reluctant to
engage in direct combat
stop hold on wait a minute because
before we continue down this path the
question you were probably wondering is
on visualpolitik josh is talking to me
about private military companies but are
these types of companies really accepted
by the international community well
let's say that here it gets a bit
complicated
you see in 1989 after several atrocities
committed by mercenary cause in africa
were made public the international
convention against the recruitment use
financing and training of mercenaries
was signed
this convention promoted by the united
nations sought to ban both mercenaries
and private military companies which he
considered little more than an evolution
of the former the idea was that by the
end of 2001 all countries would avoid
the use of mercenaries and private
military companies however to date only
46 countries have ratified it and of
course among the 46 those who make the
most of these services are nowhere to be
found not even a country like spain is
on that shortlist
[Music]
and obviously as you can imagine neither
the united states russia nor the united
kingdom by far the three countries that
make the most use of this type of
service are on the list of signatories
in any case the point is that we are
talking about a huge industry that
worldwide moves between 20 and 100
billion dollars a year and that
sometimes secures contracts as important
as these
in afghanistan over 100 billion dollars
spent on military contracts a bloomberg
report noted that in april 2021 16 832
workers were employed by contractors in
afghanistan with
6147 of them being u.s citizens that was
more than double the remaining 2 500 u.s
troops at the time yes it might come as
a surprise but the use of military units
is much more common than we might think
at first glance
companies mainly from the united states
and russia that then in turn
sub-contract in many cases or set up
local companies in the field of
operations the outcome of all of this is
that if you need an elite corp to
protect a facility if you need a team to
provide advanced military training if
you need intelligence work enemy agent
location radar control advanced missile
management whatever just pick up the
phone and ask for a quote well it's not
that simple but you get my point
[Music]
but why are we talking about russia what
is the difference what is the key aspect
that makes the russian private military
industry go so much further than the
american one and perhaps the most
important question of all if you have to
hire such a company why on earth is
russia such a popular choice well let's
take a look
[Music]
crossing the lane
why has russia become a hub for private
military companies to answer this
question we have to look back the fall
of the soviet union left thousands and
thousands and thousands of servicemen
out of work
[Music]
after the collapse of the ussr the army
experienced a significant reduction in
the number of men because there was a
huge surplus the soviet union had been a
largely militarized state after its
collapse there was no need for so many
military units and no way to pay them
this meant that many soldiers and even
officers and higher ranking personnel
had to make a living and when the only
thing you know how to do involves
military matters well that's just a
matter of course becoming a soldier of
fortune became a logical choice
[Music]
and that is not all the end of the ussr
and the collapse of its structures also
led to a significant lack of control in
the management of the arsenals
particularly in those that lay beyond
the borders of today's russia
[Music]
[Applause]
in this way for example many mi-17 and
mi24 helicopters were abandoned and left
in the hands of ex-soviet officers and
pilots who chose a lucrative outlet for
them and made a profit and this is how
the russians became so familiar with the
international military industry that
they gradually became a superpower in
this field now if we move to the
practical field why resort to these
types of companies and not use the
conventional army what on earth are
these companies actually used for well
this is a fundamental question
[Music]
you see in the case of american
companies the most accepted answer is
efficiency in some respects these
companies manage to substantially reduce
the operating costs of national armies
thanks to their specialization in very
specific areas for example there are
companies specialized in the protection
of military airfields others in the
security of perimeters in confined war
zones others in the control of
checkpoints in some cases they even
provide services that many armies
themselves are not prepared to perform
this is something we saw for example in
afghanistan the withdrawal of these
private companies made the afghan air
force practically inoperative
in the case of russian companies in
addition to these operations there are
many other reasons for example look at
this
yes i know we have talked many times
about the little green men in ukraine
and during the invasion of eastern
ukraine and crimea many media outlets
said that they were russian soldiers and
well the truth is yes and no at the same
time russian soldiers were on the ground
almost certainly it's likely all were in
service of the kremlin but it is more
likely that many of those units that
assaulted eastern ukraine were part of
military service companies contracted by
the russian government itself or close
to it which means that yes vladimir
putin may not be lying at least not
technically when he says that the
russian army did not invade ukraine
which as you can see does not mean that
russia did not invade ukraine subtle
shades of meaning in this way the
intentions and the result can be the
same although no one can be 100 sure of
the authorship we have to settle for 99
and believe me in the political arena
this is a huge difference
the thing is that russia has a long
history of using both private military
companies and mercenaries and its
history of military conflicts the most
notorious for example is the vostok
battalion formed by chechen warlord
salim yamadayef in 1999 at the beginning
of the second chechen war later this
battalion would also participate in the
war in georgia between 2007 and 2008 and
more recently in ukraine where it has
been renamed in some cases as the
donbass battalion
the point is that the methods used by
this battalion are so brutal that not
even russia openly accepts its
relationship with them the russian
government is content to say that well
they are simply local volunteers
supporting their cause you know altruism
taken to the extreme all for the
motherland russia which really means all
for uncle sam's banknotes
[Music]
the thing is that this battalion that we
have taken as an example was supposedly
disbanded in 2009 but truth is that it
never did and when 2014 rolled around
and the crisis in ukraine was building
what better strategy than to fall back
on these same troops of course it
couldn't be that obvious the outsourcing
had to be improved
to achieve this the russian government
prevented the battalion from having too
many units linked to the conflicts in
chechnya and georgia thus while the
heart of the so-called donbass unit was
made up of experienced chechen
mercenaries the bulk of the course was
made up of separatist fighters from
donetsk who had been recruited earlier
and of course it wasn't just the combat
units with supplies weapons and other
specialised services the operation was
very similar
[Music]
and yes that's how russia outsourced the
war to mercenary groups and private
military companies but visual politic
viewers it doesn't end here the question
we are wondering is what happened to all
of these groups when they are not
working for the russian government what
is going on with this industry today who
on earth are the main players well then
listen up but before just one moment
there's one word that you've probably
been hearing a lot over the past few
months inflation
central banks are printing money like
there's no tomorrow whatever it takes
and this has led to a 6.8 increase in
prices in the us alone the highest
levels in 39 years up until now the
usual way to hedge against inflation was
to invest in gold stocks or even real
estate but there are now new
alternatives and we want to show you a
very interesting one art the art market
is valued at 1.7 trillion and deloitte
estimates that it could grow to another
900 billion dollars by 2026. what's more
it's proven to be very profitable in
fact amongst the great fortunes it's a
very typical bet take the rockefeller
family they invested their fortunes to
amass one of the greatest art
collections in history which sold for a
record
835 million dollars in 2018. okay so i'm
sure you're thinking but josh why do i
care about this how am i going to
diversify my portfolio with a picasso or
warhol artwork which costs millions that
stuff is totally out of my league only
billionaires can do it well hold on
because that's where masterworks comes
in masterworks's mission is to make it
possible for anyone to invest in great
works of art through fractional shares
with masterworks you can co-own
exclusive pieces of art that help to
protect you from inflation and even make
a significant return for example they've
returned 32 to their investors in 2020
and 31 in 2021 now that's pretty
impressive considering with art that you
typically just buy and hold as opposed
to trying to understand financial
markets pour through investor reports
etc so just go to the website using our
link below to skip that wait list and
create an account after that you can
browse their selection of works like
this painting here by pablo picasso and
select how much you want to invest when
masterwork sells the painting you get
your portion of the proceeds and as
always in everything related to
investment tread carefully nothing is
risk-free but now let's continue with
today's video
[Music]
russia a private macro war hub
let's start with the question how many
private military companies do you think
there are in russia one two three maybe
five it is estimated that in total we
are talking between 10 and 20 companies
of this type being registered registered
of course in a variety of ways because
legal as such they are not although the
government itself is a good client in
any case most of them are registered as
conventional security companies of
course there is nothing much
conventional about them and not
surprisingly some stand out more than
others and many are specialized in very
specific fields
for example we have anti-terror or el a
private military company registered as a
non-governmental education and training
center in reality the company's activity
is completely different for example
anti-terror or rel is responsible for
protecting by any means possible and on
a large scale the operations of several
large russian companies in countries
such as iraq another well-known example
is moran security a military company
established by former members of the fsb
the russian secret services and the
russian navy
this company moran security for example
states on its website that it's
dedicated to escorting ships and
recovering hijacked vessels one of its
best-known operations was the rescue of
a united arab emirates ship hijacked in
1999 by sudanese but that's not all
[Music]
they also have a significant history of
ground operations including operations
in areas such as iraq and several
african countries and by the way in case
you were wondering yes the company has
its own assault vessels which have cook
islands plates and its own armoured
vehicles and pretty much anything they
need to carry out their operations
because obviously the russian government
is far from being its only client the
presence of these types of companies in
many of the most significant
international conflicts is not exactly
small but getting back to ukraine and
the presence of private military
companies in the conflict keep this name
in mind rsb group this is another
private military company registered in
2011 also by former officials of the
russian fsb and the central intelligence
department better known as gru
this company in addition to conducting
numerous ship protection operations in
african waters off somalia and the gulf
of guinea or demining operations in
libya also appears to be linked to the
invasion of ukraine the ukrainian
website infonaparm claims that rsb group
collaborated with russian-backed rebels
in the donbass and that the company was
also involved in the annexation of
crimea
vestava and skamorakov two russian
industry observers rsb group is the most
complex private military company and
perhaps the most similar to those found
in the west and especially in the united
states for example they also have their
own cyber defense department and it is
even said that they refused a request
from a state to influence the elections
of a foreign state a client which
according to them was not russia
[Music]
to show you the extent of the influence
of these companies in the last 12 years
there has been at least four attempts to
make legislative changes to fully
legalize them something that vladimir
putin himself has agreed with the
problem is that legalizing them would
mean regularizing them to a certain
extent and putting them under strict
control of the fsb the gru or the
russian ministry of defense or foreign
affairs itself so even they themselves
do not agree its current status of
sitting just beyond the law seems the
most convenient for all parties
including of course the russian
government for example have you heard of
hybrid warfare well think about it what
better way to carry it out than
resorting to these types of companies
now the question is how do you feel
about your country using these kinds of
companies would you be okay with
outsourcing some of your national
security or military operations overseas
leave us your answer below in the
comments and remember if you liked this
video like it and subscribe to our
channel and if you really like what we
do join our community on patreon every
contribution to the project is more than
welcomed once again thanks for being
here all the best see you next time
[Music]